estamos a menos de 24 horas de que
comience esta Copa Mundial de la FIFA y
no estamos hablando de fútbol estamos
hablando de esa rueda de prensa del
presidente de la FIFA gianni infantino
soy un trabajador o soy africano soy gay
fue lo que dijo el presidente de la
máxima instancia del balompié él dijo
que no fue en defensa de Qatar pero se
interpreta como un discurso de moral
frente a aquellos que han criticado esta
copa mundo aquí la primera en el mundo
árabe dijo el presidente infantino que
quizás Europa debería hacer los que
deberían estar bajo la lupa por lo que
han hecho Durante los últimos miles de
años y lo que van a hacer durante los
próximos miles de años aquí cuando
hablamos con la gente nos comentan que
son conscientes que han visto a través
de redes sociales que están bajo la lupa
que todo mundo les está mirando y son
conscientes que hay una polémica esa
polémica esas denuncias de las
organizaciones en defensa de los
Derechos Humanos que asegura que son
miles los trabajadores que han muerto en
la construcción de esos estadios desde
que llegamos a doha no hay otro tema
este país está completamente volcado con
la realización de este mundial que va a
comenzar ya el mismo domingo hablemos
ahora precisamente Juan netamente de
esta fiesta deportiva Y cómo está el
ambiente un día antes de este pitazo
inicial
a que todo el mundo respira fútbol por
las calles Es normal a los aficionados
que han llegado de varias partes del
mundo incluso residentes locales incluso
personas de países como Pakistán que no
están clasificados al mundial pero que
tienen una fuerte presencia aquí se
respira a fútbol en lo plenamente
deportivo el mundial comienza este
domingo en el estadio de albeita las
afueras de Qatar con ese partido entre
los anfitriones Qatar debutantes en un
mundial campeones de Asia frente a
Ecuador una selección que regresa una
copa mundo después de 8 años de ausencia
Hoy hubo rueda de prensa del
seleccionador de la tribu Gustavo Alfaro
y el seleccionador katari Félix Sánchez
Se pasaron la pelota cerca de quienes
favorito Gustavo Alfaro dijo que aunque
sobre el papel son superiores no se
sienten así desde Qatar dijo que lo que
le pide mañana está la afición que los
apoyen por completo en este estadio al
ba